it's a story as old as time
change is the only constant and change
is hard
after all we're only human
the change that is rolling out new
versions of your software is no
exception to this rule
even with all of the improvements
containers and kubernetes have brought
to the table
in a previous video linked below we
discussed how canary deployments in gke
can make this change for your software
easier
today let's demonstrate those
foundations and walk through the
different ways canary deployments in gke
can work
[Music]
my name is anthony bouchon developer
relations engineer here at google
in this walkthrough we'll show the
fundamentals to implicit and explicit
approaches to rolling out a canary
deployment in gke
what is out of scope for this demo is
orchestrating canary deployments as part
of an end-to-end pipeline in platforms
like cloud build or cloud deploy
want us to dive into that in the future
let us know in the comments and
subscribe to get updates
or are you still new to the overall
concept of canary deployments
check out our concepts video in the
description and come back after with
that said let's get right to it
we'll start with a single gke cluster
called prod
where we will deploy a python now
this app's only job in this world is to
tell us what version it is
i know very important
the app uses flask to return a message
that pulls its release version from an
environment variable named release using
the python os module
if we switch over to the kubernetes
manifest we can see that this
environment variable gets its value from
the pod label that references the
release version this environment
variable is set via field ref starting
in line 23 of this manifest the value of
this environment variable
will be surfaced in the responses that
different versions of our apps serve
first we have a stable release of our
app that has the appropriate release as
the key and stable as the value label
in kind
the canary release of our app will have
the appropriate release as the key
canary as the value label
it's important to note that each of
these are separate kubernetes
deployments
however they do share a common label
that allows for them to be selected by
the same kubernetes service
this means users or other clients can
access both versions of our app using
the same endpoint to be specific our
kubernetes service will route traffic to
pods with the label app name as the key
and app as the value regardless of their
differing release labels
because we are using a kubernetes
service and are using cube proxy in this
example
a pod behind the service will be chosen
at random
so let's deploy the stable and canary
version of our app and see what happens
let's set the scene first
using coupe ctx we can see that our
current cluster is the prod cluster we
showed earlier
using cubens we can see that we're
deploying all of this to the same app
namespace
and the warning you see
wouldn't worry about it for this demo
but it's a nice reminder to update your
tooling to use the out of tree gke auth
plugin
anyways using coupe ctl we'll start by
deploying the stable version of the
application starting with a single
replica of a sable pod
the pod is created so let's get the
service endpoint so we can issue a
request
because we only have the stable version
running we get the expected result
now let's deploy the canary version of
the application
also with one replica
because we now have both one stable pod
and one canary pod behind our service
let's issue a handful of requests to our
service
we can see that roughly we're getting
traffic split between the stable and
canary version
but wait a second this isn't how we roll
out a canary version of our app
if there are issues with that release we
don't want 50 of requests from users
seeing it
so let's scale up our stable version of
our deployment to 9 replicas in hopes
that we can get the majority of traffic
served from the stable version we'll
change the replicas value in the
deployment manifest
and apply the updated configuration
once kubernetes processes the update we
can see that we now have nine replicas
of our stable version running but still
only one replica of our canary version
in theory then we'd expect roughly 90 of
our traffic to be served by the stable
version
so let's see it
we'll run a while loop and issue a
handful of requests to the kubernetes
service
and as expected the majority of requests
are served by the stable replicas with
only a few served by the canary replica
scientific method at work
in a more real scenario we can leave
this canary running for a while to
observe the performance of the canary
release
gku's console gives us a quick way to
get information about the canary
deployment such as metrics around cpu
memory or even quick access to our logs
we can use all of this info to decide
when to promote our canary version of
our app to stable
all this said you might want a more
exact method for achieving a 9010
traffic split between stable and canary
versions of our app
remember how i said this method is
implicit
did you catch how
we are managing replicas explicitly not
incoming traffic
but this got us pretty close to what we
wanted
so where can this fall apart
well what if we had an autoscaler in
place
let's look at a scenario where we have a
horizontal pod auto scaler to scale our
stable deployment anywhere between 1 and
20 replicas
and because we're not sending much
traffic to our app we can see that the
pods begin to scale down this makes
keeping our desired ratio of stable to
canary replicas incredibly difficult
thus we want to look at an alternative
an explicit model for how we achieve a
canary deployment
we'll do this by evaluating the same app
but this time running in a cluster with
istio and antho service mesh
not familiar with what a service mesh is
check out the link in the description
and come back to this part of the video
after
so this time around we'll work with the
prod asm gke cluster which is running
istio and antho service mesh
if we take a look at our pods and
service we're back to where we started
one stable pod and one canary pod
one slight difference here is that we
are exposing the pods by an internal ip
rather than an external load bouncer
for those of you with eagle eyes you may
have noticed that each pod actually now
has two containers if we describe one of
the pods we can inspect and find that we
have a new container or a sidecar proxy
running alongside our app so using the
istio api and antho service mesh we
might actually be able to program these
proxies to get the explicit traffic
management we want
but right now as far as we know if we
were to send traffic to our service it
should still be 50 50 since there is one
replica of stable and one replica of
canary
we'll run a load generator pod in our
cluster to test this out
yep looks like our requests are pretty
evenly balanced
so what's the difference
well we can now create istio resources
to make the proxies in our pods aware of
traffic shaping that we may want to
implement we can start by creating an
istio destination rule for the app
service which allows us to make a
distinction between the two releases of
the app under our subsets field this
distinction is made by you guessed it
the specific label unique to the stable
and canary pods respectively
with this distinction made we can now
create an istio virtual service and
finally we can now make an explicit
reference under the weight field to the
percentages of traffic we want to go to
each subset stable and canary the
declarative values we use here are then
pushed out to the proxies in all of our
pods so that those proxies can perform
the explicit traffic shaping we want to
implement the canary deployment
with these istio resources created let's
send some traffic to our pods without
changing the replica counts for our
stable and canary releases
we can now see that roughly 90 of our
traffic is being served by the stable
pod which still only has one replica and
10 percent of our traffic being served
by the canary pod
all of this done explicitly
as a nice little bonus antho service
mesh provides us with monitoring
dashboards and the ability to create
slos to observe our canary deployments
with more user-centric metrics like
latency rather than just cpu utilization
or something like that
we can also view the overall service
mesh topology in the console for antho
service mesh
here we can see our explicit traffic
shaping in play with around 40 qps from
our load generator going to the stable
version of our app and 4 qps going to
the canary version of our app
and there we have it the fundamentals of
how you can perform canary deployments
in gke
i do want to leave you with a couple of
parting thoughts
one depending on your use case you may
not need to have a service mesh to
achieve explicit traffic shaping
check out the demo i put out on
multi-cluster gateways in the
description below to not only show how
you can use google cloud load balancers
to do explicit traffic shaping but also
how you can bring this stable canary
pattern across multiple clusters
and two at the end of the day whichever
approach you take explicit or implicit
it's all still yaml
the next step from here is to check out
what automation and pipeline software
you can use to orchestrate the
provisioning of all this yaml
to dig in deeper check out the resources
i've gathered for you here as well as
the links in the description below
let us know what you'd like to see from
this space next and as always thank you
for your time
you